mark let me just jump in here and ask
you about the IMF take on this because
they are saying yes they're shaky
markets especially what we're seeing in
it in developing markets and in Europe
but that the u.s. strength is going to
rescue us all plus you do have Mario
Draghi willing to take any step
necessary to save that economy from
another recession no no I think actually
we have fiscal policies that are
expansionary in most countries because
we still have deficits and we have
essentially monetary policies that are
financing the deficits and I think the
principal problem that the current
policy makers don't recognize is the
fact that the larger the government is
the less gross there will be the less
dynamic the economy will be one so my
question about that cuz that raises a
really interesting issue it's Barry
Ritholtz you and I know each other from
various conferences we've attached
together um yes yes all the things is
just about you yes all the things you've
mentioned European week China's slowing
down those things have all been pretty
well known for quite a while so the
question I have for you is why wednesday
and thursday and tuesday this week
couldn't this have happened any time in
the past year in fact in the u.s. it's
been something like 700 days since we've
had a ten percent correction why now why
now as opposed to any time in the past
year that is a question I'm very sorry I
cannot answer I couldn't answer why the
Nasdaq peaked out on march twenty first
two thousand and not six months earlier
or six months later these things you
just don't know but the market is
signaling
something and I would listen to the
market the market is no longer telling
you that it's a straight upward climb
right and maybe the feds can intervene
and buy shares